MALE SPEAKER: Everyone please
welcome to the stage a man
who, for decades, has redefined
the boundaries of
music and pushed the limits
of the human voice.
Here to perform from his new
album, "Spirityouall," 10 time
Grammy Award winner
Bobby McFerrin.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - BOBBY MCFERRIN,
"EVERYTIME"]
[APPLAUSE]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Thank you.
We are going to play
a few more pieces.
And then we're going to open the
floor to questions, if you
have any, or to ask any of these
members in this band.
There were six of us
this morning, but
there's three of us now.
They took different cars.
Who knows where they are?
Right.
What would you like
to play, Gil?
[LAUGHTER]
Let's play Dylan.
Let's play that song.
[BOBBY MCFERRIN SINGING
SHORT TUNE]
Shall we?
[MUSIC - BOBBY MCFERRIN,
"I SHALL BE RELEASED"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - BOBBY MCFERRIN]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Louis
has got it.
He's got it.
[MUSIC - BOBBY MCFERRIN]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Gil's got it.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - BOBBY MCFERRIN]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Thank you.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [INAUDIBLE],
you want it?
I'll sing the bass.
[MUSIC - BOBBY MCFERRIN]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Gil Goldstein
on the keyboards.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - BOBBY MCFERRIN]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [ROBOT VOICE]
Are there any questions
at this time?
Is there anything you'd like to
know about who we are and
what we do?
[MUSIC - BOBBY MCFERRIN]
[APPLAUSE]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: OK.
[SINGING]
My girl back home.
I almost forgot the
moonlight swims.
I liked her a lot.
We got engaged.
Both families were glad.
OK, ten points if you
know what that is
and where it's from.
Yes?
"South Pacific." Give this
man a round of applause.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I
came up with it.
What is the name?
Google.
Where did it come from?
MALE SPEAKER: It's, uh--
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [BABY VOICE]
Goo ga.
Daddy, goo ga.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Goo ga, daddy.
Is that-- was it from
a little kid?
MALE SPEAKER: Similar
to a word with a one
with a bunch of zeros.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I
figured that.
We, kind of, figured
that one out.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, it's
just a big number.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: It's
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Which was
named by a child.
MALE SPEAKER: Which was
Yes.
Yeah, so if you guys have any
questions for Bobby, there's
microphones on either side,
so please line up.
This is recorded for the
YouTube, so we need you on mic
to get you recorded.
So this album, I've been
listening to this, and it's
been incredible.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: And you noticed
we only played a
couple pieces.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I know.
I was wanting more.
I was itching for it.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Well, we
just didn't go there.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Well, buy the album.
Yes.
So "Spirityouall," the name of
the album, honors the legacy
of your father, which was
a very talented man.
Correct?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Yes, he was
extremely talented.
He was the first African
American to sign a contract
with the Metropolitan
Opera back in 1955.
I remember seeing his
debut in '56.
I was six years old, and it was
"Rigoletto." And he had to
where this hump on his back and
this long crooked nose.
And so at the intermission my
sister and I went backstage.
And we saw this man and we
thought, wait, is this dad?
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: You know because
he had this hump on
his back and crooked
nose and stuff.
My sister wouldn't get
anywhere near him.
MALE SPEAKER: Really?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Nowhere close.
She just would refuse to go into
the dressing because she
was convinced that that
was not papa.
You know?
MALE SPEAKER: There was
no way it could be.
And your mother too, right?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: They met
in church choir.
My mom was my dad's accompanist
for a while.
She was also a voice teacher.
Both my parents were
voice teachers.
MALE SPEAKER: So I read
somewhere that you would hide
under the piano during
her voice lessons.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: During
his lessons.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, it was
she was teaching him.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: No, no,
no, no, no, no,no.
[GIBBERISH]
Let's start over again.
MALE SPEAKER: [GIBBERISH]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [GIBBERISH]
Take it all back.
MALE SPEAKER: Good.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: My father
was teaching.
And so I would hide under the
piano when he was giving
lessons to his voice students.
So I picked up a lot of stuff.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: He was
a good teacher.
He was a great teacher.
Not a lot of politically correct
things like when
somebody does something and
they say, oh, that was
wonderful, but you can try
working on this or on that.
My dad wasn't like, oh,
that was wonderful.
No.
He was never that way.
He would say that wasn't good.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: He would just
be honest from the get go.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, that's
the best way to be.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: That's
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
And he was also the
voice of who?
For Sidney Poitier, right?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: That's right.
In the movie "Porgy
and Bess." 1958.
It's, kind of, hard
to come by.
It's difficult to get
a copy of it.
I don't think you can.
I don't think the Gershwin
estate--
MALE SPEAKER: I'm sure
we could Google it.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: You
could probably.
AUDIENCE: Ah!
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Ooh.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN:
[SPECIAL EFFECT SOUND]
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: Point made.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [GULP SOUND]
MALE SPEAKER: So the album,
you've described it as going
through a quiet revelation.
Correct?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I did?
MALE SPEAKER: Why so quiet?
I said that?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
It was in writing.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Oh yeah?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So why not just beat box it from
the top of the tallest
tower or something?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Beat box what?
MALE SPEAKER: Your revolution.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Oh,
revelation?
Oh, quiet revolution.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Oh, I thought
you said revelation.
MALE SPEAKER: No.
Did I?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: He said that.
Let's back it up.
AUDIENCE: Ah!
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Quiet
revolution.
Start all over again.
MALE SPEAKER: OK,
so the album.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [SINGING MELODY]
[SINGING]
Pick yourself up.
Dust yourself off.
And start all over again.
Thank you, ladies
and gentlemen.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: So the album--
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: We'll skip
that question.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: All right.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: So this is the
first album you produced
centered around your
faith, correct?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Well, it
certainly involves it, yeah,
because I grew up in
a Christian home.
My grandmother was a really,
really strict Catholic.
You know, fish on Friday's.
Mass every day.
She got up every morning,
around four, an prayed.
I think where I am is because
of her prayers.
And then I sang in the
children's choir in church.
I was an acolyte or
an alter boy.
I did that.
When I was about 16, I thought
of entering a monastic order
because I was really into--
I'm still very much into--
quiet.
I mean, it might not
seem like it.
But when I'm at home I
have a house in the
word, and I like quiet.
And I meditate a lot, and walk
my dog, and help my wife in
the kitchen with slicing up
vegetables for cooking or
whatever she needs.
Stuff like that.
I like quiet activities because
when I'm on stage I
get a little loose.
But it's the only time that I'm
really, kind of, a little
nutty and goofy is when I'm
here doing my tunes and
singing my songs.
MALE SPEAKER: Doing
your tunes.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [SINGING]
Oh, yes.
MALE SPEAKER: What was that?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [SINGING]
Oh, yes.
MALE SPEAKER: One more time.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [SINGING]
Oh, yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
So it's centered around
your faith.
Is this the first album you've
done that's been more of a
religious undertone?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Yes, it is.
And I wanted to do it because
I've been thinking about this
project for, at least,
20 years.
It went through all kinds of--
what's the word when it's
like permutating--
AUDIENCE: Metamorphosis.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Metamorphosis,
yeah.
It's gone through all
kinds of things.
And in the beginning, I wasn't
sure, exactly, what I wanted
"Spirityouall" to be.
But then about two years ago, I
thought maybe if I took some
of the spirituals that
my father sang.
He recorded an album of
spirituals, in 1957, on the
Riverside label called "Deep
River." And so I used that as
a basis for this album.
I didn't want to do it like my
dad because his was very--
well, not classical but he had
a classical trained voice.
I wanted to do something that
was a little more folksy and
jazzy and blue-grassy and
country and whatever.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh,
the bluegrass.
Yeah, I wanted to
touch on that.
I come from a tiny little town
in North Carolina where
bluegrass is the big thing.
So where did you get your
bluegrass influence from?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Well,
I've heard some.
Mostly, I think, in films.
Maybe a few recordings
in the past.
I've always been attracted
to it.
We were in Ireland about three
years ago, and we played in a
little town called Limerick.
And they were having
a reception for me.
So I'm supposed to walk in and
shake hands with all these
guests, have my picture taken,
sign autographs,
and stuff like that.
And when I walked through the
door, there was a band playing
in the corner.
And they were playing
genuine Irish music.
I mean, the old traditional
stuff with the pipes, and the
violin, the fiddle, and all that
kind of stuff, which is
where our bluegrass
music comes.
So I, sort of, gravitated
over there.
Set in a chair and just hung
out with the band while all
these people are waiting for
me to have my picture taken
with them and stuff like that.
And I completely ignored them.
I couldn't help myself because
the music was so inviting.
And it really pulled me
into their center.
I just was stuck there.
I set down and I could not
believe what I was hearing
because it was such
beautiful music.
I love the plain, simple rhythms
of the American heart.
I love jazz.
I love Bluegrass.
Anything that's come out of
the soil, even though
Bluegrass really is
from Ireland.
[IRISH ACCENT]
And I tried so hard to talk
like an Irishman.
But they wouldn't let
me because they said
it's not that good.
You know?
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [IRISH ACCENT]
But I tried.
You know, the secret to
it, I think, is if you
don't move your lips.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: [IRISH ACCENT]
You just got to talk like
this [IRISH ACCENT]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [IRISH ACCENT]
You smile like that, right.
And you start to talk.
And that's the best way that
I can think of doing it.
But it's not that
good, you know.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: [IRISH ACCENT]
When I get into me Irish accent,
I always have to start
going tar, tar, tar, tar.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [IRISH ACCENT]
Tar, tar,tar, tar.
MALE SPEAKER: [IRISH ACCENT]
It just helps it out
a little bit.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [IRISH ACCENT]
Ah, right.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: Let's take
a question over here.
AUDIENCE: I hope
you don't mind,
but I have two questions.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: What?!
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, well.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: OK.
AUDIENCE: The first is I've seen
a number of musicians who
sing as they play, which
I always thought
was fascinating listening.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Sing
as they play.
AUDIENCE: That they know their
instrument so well that
they're singing along with their
playing, doing a solo.
But you were playing while
you're singing.
What instrument are you
playing on that mic?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Oh, this?
You know, I played clarinet
when I was 10.
And I have a feeling that this
was a carry-over of it.
And it gives me a tactile
connection to the notes.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [SINGING NOTES]
You know?
[SINGING NOTES]
AUDIENCE: Well, it's
very consistent.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I couldn't
tell what it was.
It could be keyboards or--
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Recorder.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Second question is, there was,
at least, two times this
afternoon where you started
singing something, and after a
short time your keyboardist
started playing.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So which is it?
Are you starting in the correct
key because you've got
perfect pitch?
Or is he picking up the
key you're singing in?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: He's picking up
the key that I'm singing.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: He's
got good ears.
I have imperfect peach.
Peach.
MALE SPEAKER: Peaches?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Imperfect
peach.
MALE SPEAKER: Imperfect
peaches?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Start
all over again.
[SINGING]
Start all over again.
MALE SPEAKER: Rewind it.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [GIBBERISH]
MALE SPEAKER: [GIBBERISH]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Imperfect
pitch.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: I kept saying
peach in my head too.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I had
to think about that.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering what you sound
like when your stuffed up, and
if they're any sounds you can
make only when you're stuffed
up that you wished you had?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [SINGING]
Every little [INAUDIBLE].
I have no idea what I
sound like though.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN:
[STUFFED UP VOICE]
I've never attempted to sing
anything when I'm on stage.
I couldn't possibly do this.
I'd have to stop.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN:
[STUFFED UP VOICE]
But I could try.
I could say, ladies and
gentleman, this is the best I
can do for tonight.
So I'll--
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN:
[STUFFED UP VOICE]
--sing for about 30 minutes,
and then I'll have to stop.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Sounds about right.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: The
answer is no.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: All right.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: You only have
one question, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: OK.
MALE SPEAKER: What if you have
a drummer who keeps sneezing?
LOUIS CATO: That happens
sometimes.
MALE SPEAKER: You keep hitting
your head on the symbols?
LOUIS CATO: That also happens.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi, I want to
thank you for coming.
I been listening to
you my whole life.
My question is sort of random.
It's about your multi-tonal
stuff that you do.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Multi tonal.
AUDIENCE: Like when you sing
harmony with yourself, I just
have to say, it's bad-ass.
It's so cool.
And my question is how
did you discover that
you could do that?
And what was your inspiration?
And how can I do that?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: OK,
let me tell you.
I worked on my technique for
six years before I did my
first solo concert.
I practiced, at least,
two hours a day.
I took a tape recorder with
me everywhere I went.
I purposely stayed away from
listening to other singers, on
purpose, because I'm very
impressionable.
I was afraid that, if I found a
singer that I liked, I would
latch on to their technique
and I'd never find myself.
So I did a few things.
I practiced for six years.
I recognized, also, that what
I wanted to do involved more
than singing notes.
You had to sing character.
You had sing color.
You had to sing language.
And so I started experimenting,
not only with
the notes, but the texture
of the notes.
The approach of the notes.
The dynamics of the notes.
The weight of the notes.
All that stuff had
to go into it.
I could see myself
onstage alone.
I couldn't hear anything
initially, but as I started to
sing a lot and practice a lot,
creating all kinds of
exercises, and singing
intervals of tenths.
Working on my chest voice
and my head voice.
[SINGING]
Chest.
Head.
Things like that.
So it just involved a
lot of singing over
and over and over.
Just all the time.
Singing two records.
You know, instrumentalists.
Singing over changes.
Changes meaning chord changes.
That's it.
Being a character.
Having fun.
Just giving yourself permission
to sing and sound
like anything.
You know?
AUDIENCE: And what about the
two notes at once thing?
BOBBY MCFERRIN:
[SINGING A NOTE SOUND]
That's buzzing your lips for
one tone and then humming.
[SINGING NOTE SOUND]
That's it, sort of.
It's no secret.
AUDIENCE: So cool.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: You can hum
and whistle too.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I can what?
AUDIENCE: Hum and whistle.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Hum
and whistle.
I wish I could come
hum and whistle.
I can't.
I know someone who can whistle
and hum in counterpoint.
And she has a sister who
can do the same thing.
So they do four part
Bach things.
It's pretty amazing.
And her name is Irene
Goodnight.
[SINGING]
Goodnight Irene.
Do, do, dee.
Yes?
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
So touching back, talking about
when you were starting
to sing, you had a band when
you where 14, right?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I lived
in Los Angeles.
I had a band called The
Fascinations when I was 14.
I've been a working musician
since I was 14.
I'm 63, so what is that?
Is that 50 years, almost 50
years, working as a musician.
And I had a band called
The Fascinations.
We played the top 40 stuff
that was on the
radio at the time.
MALE SPEAKER: So you where
piano at that point.
Pianist, right?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I was a
piano player, right.
MALE SPEAKER: So what
was in the band?
You guys had the piano.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Piano, guitar,
lead guitar, rhythm guitar,
drums, and lead singer.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
wonderful.
OK, question over here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hey there.
Sorry I got laryngitis.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [SINGING]
You were the stars--
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
what's up man.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [SINGING]
--in your eyes.
AUDIENCE: But you know the one
that goes [SINGING TUNE SOUND]
AUDIENCE: [SINGING NOTES]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Oh.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I Yeah.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: And the part
where the car goes by.
[SPECIAL EFFECT SOUND
OF CAR GOING BY]
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC - BOBBY MCFERRIN,
"DRIVE"]
[SPECIAL EFFECT SOUND
OF CAR GOING BY]
[MUSIC - BOBBY MCFERRIN,
"DRIVE"]
[APPLAUSE]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Thank you.
Thank you.
There's a question down here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Did you ever
get unhappy singing
Don't Worry Be Happy?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Do
you know what?
Let me tell you.
The answer to that is no
because, by the time you heard
the tune, I had sung it
500 trillion times.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So how do you keep
making it new and magical?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I don't sing
it anymore in concert.
I haven't sung it all the way
through in at least 20 years.
It was probably like 1988,
1989, something like that
because I got, basically, tired
of singing the song.
Now the blessing is, nowadays,
I go on YouTube and I'll find
these eight-year-old kids
singing [SINGING]
Don't Worry Be Happy
[SINGING SMALL TUNE].
So I like watching these
multi-generational people just
falling in love with this
tune and singing it.
They're playing it
in karaoke bars.
Grunge bands are playing it.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: A cappella
groups are singing it.
And it's just a blessing
for me.
MALE SPEAKER: You also did "The
Cosby Show" theme song.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I did.
[SINGING "THE COSBY
SHOW" THEME]
Yes, I did.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [SINGING
"THE COSBY SHOW" THEME]
MALE SPEAKER: This is
a shot in the dark.
Do you know who or did you
do the "Doug" theme song?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: The "Doug"?
MALE SPEAKER: On Nickelodeon.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I don't
even know who Doug is.
Who's Doug?
MALE SPEAKER: I guess not.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: No.
MALE SPEAKER: Anyway, it's
very similar genres.
So I didn't know if you had
any influence over that.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I
didn't do it.
No.
MALE SPEAKER: Go on
YouTube then.
It's pretty good.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: All right,
if you say so.
[BRITISH ACCENT]
You think it's worth it
to go check it out?
MALE SPEAKER: [BRITISH ACCENT]
I think you'll like it.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [BRITISH ACCENT]
You think so?
MALE SPEAKER: [BRITISH ACCENT]
I do.
I do, governor.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [BRITISH ACCENT]
Oh.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, so going
on to the future.
Well, before I go there, let's
take this question over here.
BOBBY MCFERRIN:
[DEEP MOVIE PREVIEW VOICE]
In a world where time
travel exists--
MALE SPEAKER: You can do that!
BOBBY MCFERRIN:
[DEEP MOVIE PREVIEW VOICE]
--one man dared to enter
the time traveler.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm jealous
of that skill.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Well,
just try it.
MALE SPEAKER: [DEEP VOICE]
In a-- no.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: No.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN:
[DEEP MOVIE PREVIEW VOICE]
See, you've got to have
two elements.
The first one is in a world.
MALE SPEAKER: In a world.
[DEEP VOICE]
In a world.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: And
then, one man.
MALE SPEAKER: [DEEP VOICE]
In a world.
BOBBY MCFERRIN:
[DEEP MOVIE PREVIEW VOICE]
In a world.
MALE SPEAKER: [DEEP VOICE]
BOBBY MCFERRIN:
[DEEP MOVIE PREVIEW VOICE]
One man.
MALE SPEAKER: [DEEP VOICE]
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Ba da bing.
MALE SPEAKER: Question please.
AUDIENCE: It is such a treat
to hear you in person.
Thank you so much for coming.
I just want to tell you that
your album, "Circle Songs," is
something that, for years, I've
always turned to if I
needed some spiritual
uplifting.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Yeah, thanks.
AUDIENCE: So I want to thank
you, in person, for that one.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: You're
very welcome.
AUDIENCE: Also, my hometown
is Saint Paul, Minnesota.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: And I was wondering
how you enjoyed working there
when you were working
with them?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I loved it
because, when they hired me, I
was a brand new conductor.
I had no clue what to
do with the Saint
Paul Chamber Orchestra.
I didn't know how to rehearse.
I hadn't settled on any kind
of stick technique, of any
kind, to lead the orchestra.
Hand technique.
So they were very, very
patient with me.
They hired me with no
understanding of what they
were getting into.
And I worked with them for six
seasons or seven seasons, one
or the other, and they were
my first teachers.
And this is a revelation.
I'm spending a lot of time
trying to be a conductor.
So I figured you had to
talk like a conductor.
Clarinets on bar 92.
A little bit more diminuendo
at the end of the phrase.
Blah, blah, blah.
And finally, I just
wasn't getting it.
And, dadgum it, the woodwind
section comes to me one day in
my dresser room.
And they said, why don't
you just sing to us?
Duh, you know?
What a revelation that was.
And so from then on, when I
wanted something from a
particular section of the
orchestra, I'd sing it.
And that would give them
all the information.
The flexibility of the phrase.
The dynamics of the phrase.
How long the phrase went.
How long it lasted.
And that was a revelation
for me.
And I don't know why
didn't think of it.
I mean, I'm a singer,
after all.
Instead of trying to sound very
conductorial they said,
just sing to us.
We'll get it.
But just sing.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
That's beautiful.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I loved it.
I had a great time.
[SINGING SHORT TUNE]
AUDIENCE: I have a little bit
more of a technical question.
I am very impressed with the
effects you do in your voice.
But I can't help but notice that
I believe there's some
reverb going on or some delay.
Is this just my mind playing
tricks on me?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: No,
it depends.
Sometimes there's
a little delay,
depending on what I'm doing.
Ive been working with
the sound man, Danny
Vicari for 25 years.
He knows me really,
really well.
So he'll just, maybe, put a
little delay on something.
No, you're not hearing
anything.
You're not hearing anything.
You know.
AUDIENCE: I couldn't tell.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So in that case, I'll
grab a second question.
So I always felt that voice is
a very natural kind of thing.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And at least right
now, ever since '70s and '80s
delays, going digital, I feel
that they mess up a lot of it.
They take a lot of neutrality.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Yeah,
auto-tune.
Boo.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, what's
your opinion on that?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I don't
like a lot of it.
I don't like manipulating
of the voices a lot.
I think it's an excuse for
not being talented.
A lot of singers rely
on it to help them
sing in tune or whatever.
I don't really want
to get into it.
It's a waste of time for me.
I don't explore it.
I knew at the beginning that I
didn't want to use any effects
doing solo concerts because I
was afraid that if I got in
trouble doing an improv, and
it wasn't working, that I'd
bail myself out by clicking a
switch and bringing up some
kind of an effect.
I didn't want to do that, so
I stayed away from it.
I like to do everything
organically.
MALE SPEAKER: Have you ever got
in trouble in a concert?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: No.
MALE SPEAKER: Then
you're all set.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Well, you
know, it's improv.
If you mess up, you don't really
mess up in improv.
MALE SPEAKER: Just do it again,
and it sounds like you
did it on purpose.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Do it again.
Sounds like you did
it on purpose.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Or maybe what
you messed up took you
someplace that you hadn't
intended on going.
And you find something that you
would not have found if
you had stuck with your
original intent.
MALE SPEAKER: So how long have
you been playing with these
two fellows?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Well, Gil and I
have been playing together,
off and on, for a few years.
Maybe, five or six or
something like that.
Maybe even longer.
Seven or eight.
Whatever.
And Louis since, maybe, April.
LOUIS CATO: End of
March, yeah.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: End of March.
Beginning of April.
MALE SPEAKER: You're
very tight.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Yeah, I should
also say that there's three
other members of the band who
weren't here today because I
don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I guess they
thought there wasn't enough
space on stage for everyone.
But we have three additional
players.
Bass, acoustic bass, and
two guitar players.
One guy plays it's pedal
steel, slide, mandolin,
fiddle, and acoustic.
And then the other guy plays
acoustic and electric guitar.
And then with Cato playing
guitar, sometimes we have
three guitars playing.
So including myself, it's
a six member band.
Six piece band.
MALE SPEAKER: Wow.
So how much time do you spend
rehearsing improvisation?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Now?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Well,
every day.
I don't know how much time,
but I sing every day.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
I mean, not you.
But I mean as a whole band
because you guys have to know.
You start learning each
other, and you
learn about each other.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Yeah, but
they have great ears.
If I take off and start to
improvise and come out with
some really off the wall place
that I want to go, they pick
it up really quickly.
MALE SPEAKER: Was that part
of the audition process?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Probably.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Just give them a
beat, and see if they can make
it sound good?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Yeah, sure.
MALE SPEAKER: That's not bad.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This might be a bit of
a broad question.
But I was wondering if you could
tell us about a time
when there was some vocal effect
that really gave you
difficulty in learning how to do
it and, ultimately, getting
it the way you wanted
it to sound.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: No, my approach
was never to listen
to a sound and try
to imitate it.
I never went for that.
AUDIENCE: You just made them
all up from scratch.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I would just
make them all up on the spot.
I'd give myself different
exercises to play.
Like, say, for two
minutes, I'm only
going to sing one note.
So how many different
ways can I sing it?
Things like that.
I would give myself all kinds of
musical challenges to face.
That's all.
But I never would listen
to a sound.
A lot of people say, well, you
sound just like a trumpet.
Well, I never studied
the trumpet.
I never listened to the trumpet
and tried to emulate
it or imitate it.
Imitate it.
I never tried to do that.
It was always just trying,
getting things out of me or
from the inside out.
AUDIENCE: It sounds like there's
all sorts of sound
effects that you can do.
You must have learned
how to make the
car sound, for instance.
That's, certainly, imitating
something.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Well, I use
what I hear, basically.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: [SINGING]
You're welcome.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: So I guess we're
running low on time here.
To wrap it all up, here you are
now, and you've come so
far in your career.
Where do you see
yourself going?
What's the next step?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: I don't
really know.
I'd like to write more.
I put some new equipment in my
studio in my house, recently,
and I hope to get to it when I
have a nice span of time that
I can devote to it.
I have a hard time writing
when I'm traveling.
That's one thing.
And that's probably it.
Right now, I'm just into playing
with these guys.
MALE SPEAKER: Have you ever
thought about collaborating
with your children at all
because they're also very
musical, right?
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Well, I have.
In fact, my daughter sings
in this band when
she's got a free day.
She's got a band of her own.
And when she's not working
with them, she joins us.
And then my oldest son,
Taylor McFerrin--
you can, probably,
find him online.
He does a lot of things--
we've worked together
a few times.
We did two dates in Paris and
two dates in London a few
years back.
2007, I think.
And then my middle
child's an actor.
And he's out on auditions
all the time.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, I appreciate
you coming in.
BOBBY MCFERRIN: Oh, yeah.
My pleasure.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, so everybody
please visit him
online. bobbymcferrin.com.
You got a Twitter account
@bobbymcferrin.
Facebook/bobbymcferrin.
And then I've been listening to
him all week on our Google
Play music all access.
It's been incredible.
So thank you very much.
Give him another round
of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - BOBBY MCFERRIN]
BOBBY MCFERRIN:
[SINGING IN ROBOT VOICE]
Goodnight.
[APPLAUSE]